hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video
we're going to talk about how exposure
to warm temperatures
have been shown in a recent study to
prevent bone loss
by acting through the gut microbiome and
so this is a really intriguing study
that brings together
a lot of different fields and it also
has particular relevance for trying to
identify
treatment options for osteoporosis a
disease manifested by bone loss and
increased fracture risk
and these two features are also
age-associated conditions
and so as we'll explore later on in this
video we
will look at how alternative ways of
mimicking this approach
could potentially have future
therapeutic use
so i shamelessly stole the title of this
video from the cell metabolism paper
warmth prevents bone loss through the
gut microbiota because i mean it pretty
much
sums up nicely what this whole study is
about
and so to break down this video i'll
begin by introducing
just a general overview to osteoporosis
and bone formation
and then we'll dive into this research
paper that for the majority of it
focuses on mice whereby they expose the
mice to warm temperatures
and try to understand how warm exposure
prevented bone loss and discovering that
this process was mediated through
changes within the gut microbiome
so we'll introduce the gut microbiome
briefly and also
talk about the metabolites that they saw
change during this warmth exposure
but as we all know we are not mice
however interestingly
the authors of this study also performed
a human meta-analysis
of the incidence of hip fractures and
their correlation with temperature so
we'll look at that data as well
and then lastly i'll summarize some of
the take-homes from this research paper
some of the limitations but some of the
further questions said it raises
and potential applications of this
knowledge to
treatments so firstly then what is
osteoporosis
well it's the most prevalent metabolic
bone disease
that results in weaker bones and
increased fracture risk
and this is characterized by a loss of
bone mass
and changes within the microarchitecture
of the bone
and i also want to point out that this
is different to osteoarthritis which i
mentioned whilst talking about unity
biotechnology
in a video a while ago which is
degeneration of a joint
whilst osteoporosis is the loss of bone
mass
and so both of these are age-associated
diseases
but interestingly the most common type
of primary osteoporosis
occurs as a result of post-menopausal
estrogen deficiency and so
bone remodeling is an active process
that is coordinated
by two different cell types osteoblasts
and osteoclasts osteoblasts
are responsible for bone formation and
osteoclasts
are involved in bone resorption so
osteoclasts
break down bone tissue and so the
activity of these different types of
cells
fluctuates as the bone responds to
external stimuli and different
environmental
stressors so what does bone remodeling
have to do with temperature
well as described by one of the authors
of the paper
we were inspired by the fact that mice
living in warm temperatures
increased their tail length which is a
way for them to dissipate heat
we assumed that heat applied
post-developmentally in healthy
and during osteoporotic states might
have beneficial effects on bone strength
and so this is the idea that rodents
living in hotter temperatures
to be able to dissipate more of that
heat they can increase their surface
area to volume ratio
and one way that can be achieved is by
having a longer tail
and so the hypothesis is that
temperature can influence
bone development and the idea that the
authors had
is to investigate whether or not that
could be exploited
to help prevent bone deterioration that
occurs during osteoporosis
so to test the hypothesis they needed a
good model
and a good model for primary
osteoporosis
are surgically ovariactimized mice
and then to directly test if warmer
temperatures
could exert protective effects on bone
loss they performed the surgery on 16
week old mice
and then either exposed them to 34
degrees
or room temperature for eight weeks and
the remarkable thing
was that the warmth exposure prevented
the bone loss seen
in the control mice so the obvious
question that this raises
was why and how was this happening and
so this is where we come onto the gut
microbiome
which amongst its many influences within
our bodies
has also been shown to be an important
regulator of bone remodeling
and so i've made several videos talking
about the gut microbiome which includes
all the different
bacteria fungi and viruses that reside
within our bodies
and the composition of this microbiome
can be influenced by various factors
for example i made a video talking about
how diet can influence the microbiome
but several studies have also shown how
it can influence bone metabolism
so given this information the authors
decided to analyze the microbiome
composition
of 24 week old female mice that has been
exposed to 34 degrees for eight weeks
by comparing the data to controls they
can see that there are clear differences
in the microbiome composition
for example they could see a strong
increase in the abundance of
akamancia mucini fila i
probably said that wrong anyway to show
that the microbiome is important
in these alterations in bone remodeling
they repeated the experiments
by one firstly applying antibiotics
which prevented the increases in bone
strength seen with the warmth exposure
and secondly they transplanted the
microbiota
of warm adapted mice to a very ectomised
mice
which also was shown to prevent the bone
loss and so this highlighted the
importance of the microbiome composition
and its change during the warmth
exposure the question is
what about that change caused the
changes seen in the bone remodeling
so to answer this question the authors
used a combination of meta genomics
whereby they could look at what
different biochemical pathways were
being up regulated
and metabolomics to see how different
metabolites changed in concentration
during warmth exposure
one pathway that stood out was an
increase in polyamine synthesis
but polyamines include a variety of
different organic compounds
and so specifically what they saw was an
increase in the levels of genes
responsible for the production of
spermadine
and a decrease in the number of genes
involved in the degradation of
spermadine
and this is particularly interesting
because a previous study
showed that mice that were given overall
supplementation of
spermine and bermadine in an ovary
ectomy
induced model of osteoporosis was
sufficient to prevent bone loss
and this is an agreement with what the
authors of this paper found
when they supplemented spermadine at
high doses in osteoclasts
and saw that it down regulated some of
the key markers of their activity
and so if you remember from the start of
the video osteoclasts
are the cells that break down the bone
tissue and so this could explain
the impacts that they were seeing during
the warmth exposure of the mice
such that warmth exposure alters the
microbiome composition
such that it results in a greater
production of these polyamines including
spermadine
that could have the downstream
influences of altering the activity of
the osteoclasts
and therefore altering the balance
between the osteoclasts and osteoblasts
preventing this deterioration of bone
loss that's often seen in the
ovarectomized mice
and so this data suggests that
mechanisms that can increase the number
of species within the gut microbiome
that can generate
spermadine or through alternative ways
of boosting spamadine levels
could be therapeutic options for
preventing the symptoms that are seen
that result in osteoporosis and i like
the way that
it's described in this article
summarizing the paper that suggests that
a treatment that would involve
increasing spermadine levels would be
very welcomed since spamadine has also
been shown
to have potential anti-aging properties
and so along with being able to prevent
the bone deterioration
it might be able to help decrease
hypertension memory impairment
myopathy and carcinogenesis and so the
data is potentially interesting
however as i said this is done in mice
what about humans
well in the study they performed a human
meta-analysis
on the incidence of hip fractures per
capita and country worldwide
what they could see in the dataset was
that there was a negative correlation
between the average temperature and the
incidence of hip
fractures so what this means is that the
higher the temperature
the lower the incidence of hip fractures
and so this kind of
supports potentially their data whereby
warmth exposure
to the higher temperatures prevented the
deterioration of the bone loss seen in
the overectomized mice
moreover they showed that by normalizing
the analysis
to other known factors that could alter
bone strength such as calcium intake and
vitamin d
did not influence this correlation
further supporting
the importance of temperature in bone
remodeling
but this is just a correlation still and
it will be important to gather further
evidence
to examine this link between warmth or
spermadine increase
and bone remodeling and so other
questions that this paper raises
includes what about the temperature
changes is able to alter the microbiota
composition
for example our body temperatures remain
pretty constant even
fluctuations to higher or lower
temperatures and so it's kind of
fascinating that they did see
such dramatic changes within the
composition of the microbiome
just by having exposure to higher
temperatures moreover this study
suggests
a link between the polyamine production
and the
changes seen in the bone remodeling but
that doesn't necessarily mean that there
might be other changes within the
microbiome or other
beyond the microbiome changes that are
causing this effect
nonetheless this reinforces how cool the
gut microbiome is
or well in this case how hot the gut
microbiome is
and so on that note i hope you've
learned something and as always
thanks for listening